feminism and the way people dress women
becoming more masculine they don't know
why they're doing it now they may not be
doing it for feminist reasons but like a
man not wanting to take responsibility
for his family and being a protector and
a provider that might just be because
you know it's not he's not doing it
because he's standing against society
he's just doing it because it's the norm
now so now all these backwards ways have
become the norm then we have to
understand what is that new normal i
hate that term but what is that what
does that mean like what does that mean
it means in terms of like the pronouns
things it means what you were saying
we're now living in a reality whereby we
don't base things on facts who based
things on emotions which is dangerous if
you can pick your gender why can't you
pick your age why can't a grown man say
you're hurting my feelings if you don't
believe me when i say i feel like i'm
five why can't i sleep in that little
girl's bed we're best friends she likes
me you're hurting my feelings this is
the norm and then if we start having the
norm which is super you know masculine
women and then very feminine men what
does that mean if this flips and women
are now men and men are women what
happens to procreation